all right so today is the third lecture
in our first part of the class on
complex analysis so there's going to be
three more lectures next week and I
would say the next week is going to get
pretty interesting we're going to learn
how to solve some really really nasty
integrals that you probably never
thought you'd be able to solve without
Mathematica now the importance of
solving interesting and difficult
integrals is something I'll have to
motivate and explain kind of in detail
next week but for now just take my word
for the fact that there's lots of things
you want to integrate and knowing
something about analytic functions in
the complex plane allows you to
integrate a lot more stuff than you
learned in calculus class okay so this
is like calculus on steroids at this
point okay I just want to show you
homework 1 homework 1 is out and it's
due next Friday this homework is it
might look a little bit long it is a
little long because it's a two-week
homework but the first three problems
are actually super simple okay so for
example I want you to take these three
expressions and just write them as a
plus bi where a and B are real easy find
all of the solutions of these equations
e to the Z equals 1 e to zequals I is
equal to I plus 1 just a quick question
how would you go about solving that
general type of equation for Z right you
would essentially take the log of both
sides and how many values of the
logarithm are there yeah how many log
how many Z's are there such that log of
Z equals such that Z equals log of 1
infinitely many right because for every
angle of Z you can add 2 pi or subtract
2 pi as many times as you want so this
is an easy problem find all of the
solutions of these Z to the fourth
equals minus 1 Z to the third
equals eight is Z to the fifth equals
one right these are this is what we did
last lecture I would encourage you to
try and do as much of this homework as
possible as soon as possible because
this is actually going to motivate a lot
of what we're going to do next week
especially the second half I'm going to
skip all this stuff you're going to do
things like find whether or not a
function is analytic using the Cauchy
Riemann conditions you're going to find
all possible analytic functions such
that the real part is x squared minus y
squared the two most interesting
problems are one seven and one eight and
so what I want you to do here is we're
actually going to start thinking about
contour integrals in the complex plane
okay that's what we're going to do in
the second half of today and all of next
week our contour integrals in the
complex plane and so this is a nice
simple contour integral where if you
plug in this parameterization for Z so
if you integrate around a big circle
with fixed radius you can analytically
solve this contour integral and this is
going to motivate a lot of what we're
going to do next week and for this last
problem you're actually going to write a
script in MATLAB to compute the contour
integral and you're going to verify some
of the properties that we're going to
derive today and on Monday okay so it's
not a terribly difficult homework but it
does have a lot of parts and you know if
you could get through all of this or at
least look at all of them by the end of
Monday's lecture you know that would be
kind of the right time frame to be
keeping up with with the material next
week any questions okay I think that's
it for the computer okay
you
all right so I'm going to do a couple of
things today so first we're just going
to we're just going to take summarize
what we did in the last lecture which is
we got to the Koshi riemann conditions
we're going to use the Koshi remind
conditions to show that the logarithm
function is in fact a nice analytic
function and then we're going to start
looking at contour integrals in the
complex plane okay so from last time so
we had these special functions which are
called analytic functions and the basic
idea of an analytic function is that you
can take the derivative of analytic
functions at points where that function
is analytic okay you can take the
derivative and it doesn't matter how you
take the limits you know as Delta Z goes
to 0 in the real part of the imaginary
part the derivative still exists and
it's equal and so we derived these Koshi
riemann conditions and these Koshi
riemann conditions tell you when a
function is going to be analytic ok so
if I have f of z equals u plus IV so you
as a real valued function V is also a
real valued function then F of Z is
analytic if and only if 2x means if and
only if the following conditions hold we
have partial u partial x equals partial
V partial Y and partial V partial x
equals minus partial u partial Y ok so
this is a really nice simple formula
that allows us to check whether or not a
function is in fact analytic ok and we
essentially derived these conditions by
taking our function f and computing the
derivative at a point Z and taking the
limit both in the real
direction and in the imaginary direction
separately and these are the conditions
that have to be true if those
derivatives equal each other okay so
this is a statement of the fact that
this has derivatives which exist at
points Z or F is analytic so why don't
we just do a couple of quick easy
examples so I told you that all
polynomials are analytic right
polynomials are analytic sine and cosine
are analytic e to the Z are analytic
anything that has a convergent Taylor
series expansion is analytic and
anything that's analytic has a
convergent Taylor series expansion
that's very very important let's just
take this simple function Z squared so
how do I get U and V for this function
what is what's the first step sorry
yeah I just plug in X plus iy and I foil
it out I just expand it out so this is X
plus iy
squared which is x squared minus y
squared plus 2i XY right ok and this
real part is U of x and y and this
imaginary part
you know 2xy equals my V of X and y so
let's just verify that these kochira
mind conditions hold for this simple
function so we know that this is
analytic because it's literally an
analytic expression of Z it's not just a
function of x and y and we're pretty
sure we can take the derivative of this
function in any direction so let's just
go through the partials so partial u
partial x equals 2x partial V partial y
equals 2x okay good the first Koshi
ramond condition is satisfied because
these two equal each other
partial V partial x equals 2y and
partial u partial y equals minus 2y and
so ii Kochi Ramon condition is also
satisfied ok so the fact that these two
these expressions equal each other means
that at any point and this is also true
for any point Z right any Z equals X
plus iy that you name these are true for
any X and for any Y and so this function
is analytic and differentiable
everywhere and clearly it has a
convergent Taylor series because it's
just a single monomial okay so that's
like a really really simple example of
how you use these Koshi Riemann
conditions so because these are true
this implies that F is in fact analytic
and it's not just analytic at a couple
of points in Z its analytic at all Z in
the complex plane ok makes sense so I'm
just going to do another slightly more
detailed example so you can you can
derive polar coordinate expressions for
the Koshi riemann conditions i thought
about putting this on the homework but i
decided it's a better exam problem so if
you had Koshi riemann in polar
coordinates you would have something
like so now we're going to say that z
equals r e to the I theta and we're
still going to have f of Z equals u but
now this is a function of r and theta
plus IV times the function of r and
theta right we can write our our complex
variable in polar coordinates and our
function still has a real and an
imaginary part
and so the coachee Ramon conditions in
polar coordinates would read like the
following partial u partial R equals 1
over R partial V partial theta and also
we have to have partial V partial R
equals minus 1 over R partial V partial
sorry partial u partial u partial theta
our might used in V is impossible to
tell apart so you have a lot of trouble
reading my using V's I used to have a
physics professor that would write
pressure and density and it drove me
crazy
so my use always have this little tail
that's how you can tell that there use
so these are the polar coordinate Koshi
riemann conditions okay and these are
useful for solving for demonstrating
that certain functions are analytic that
are more easily expressed in polar
coordinates so of the functions that
we've looked at what are some functions
that are more easily expressed in polar
coordinates okay I mean Z squared is
actually pretty easily expressed in
polar coordinates so I have an example
in the notes for log Z I'll just let you
do that like on your own time let's just
do this example
ok so Z squared equals R squared e to
the 2i theta right ok and that has a
real part R squared coast 2 theta and an
imaginary part R squared sine 2 theta ok
so this is my function U and this is my
function V I'm actually starting to
think that this was easier in Cartesian
coordinates but we'll go with it so what
is partial u partial R partial u partial
R
to our coast to theta okay what's
partial V partial theta its 2r squared
times the derivative of this is Coast -
theta okay so it is true that if I take
DV d theta divided by R I get 2 UDR
right so that Cauchy Riemann condition
is satisfied the first one
okay partial V partial R is 2 R sine 2
theta and partial u partial theta is
minus 2 R squared sine 2 theta and so
this has the same relationship where if
I divide this by R and take the negative
I get the top expression so both Koshiro
my conditions are satisfied in Cartesian
and in polar coordinates ok this is not
the best example of an easy something
that's easier in polar coordinates but
log is actually a lot easier polar
coordinates okay everyone comfortable
with the mechanics of this so you're
going to be doing this for the function
e to the Z the exponential function and
also for the function sine of Z and you
should also be able to do it for the
function coasts of Z that might be the
kind of thing that would be on an exam
like I might just give you some
functions and ask you if they're
analytic or not or I might yeah that
would be something I would do okay so
one of the really really really neat
properties of analytic functions is that
analytic functions if a function is
analytic then it is the solution of
Laplace's equation so do you remember
what Laplace's equation is ok so let me
just write this down if a function f of
Z
equals U of X y plus IV XY is analytic
then both U and V so U and V are real
value functions right X is a real number
y is a real number
U and V are both real valued functions
then both U and V solve Laplace's
equation and Laplace's equation is grad
squared u equals 0 grad squared V equals
0 this is called the laplacian operator
and it's you know grad sorry del dot
grad IV something like that okay we look
at this last quarter did I already show
you the picture of Laplace on the eiffel
tower
no it's pretty sweet all of the people
that we're studying in complex analysis
like more than half of them are on the
eiffel tower their names are forever
ingrained on the Eiffel Tower because
French people honor their mathematicians
and they had a lot of really really
great ones ok so I'm going to show you
why this is true so essentially what
we're going to do is we're going to take
the Koshi riemann conditions and take
additional derivatives of them so Koshi
riemann one is partial u partial x
equals partial V partial Y and Koshi
riemann two is partial u partial y
equals minus partial V partial X and so
what I'm going to do is take the partial
of both sides of this with respect to X
and with respect to Y so a partial
partial X partial partial Y and we get
something like
partial squared u partial x squared
equals partial squared V partial X
partial Y and down here we get partial u
partial Y squared equals minus partial V
partial X partial Y simple I just took
the derivative of both sides and like
making stuff up here I just take the
derivatives but what I can do is I can
actually equate because I have a partial
squared V partial X partial Y and I have
the same thing here but negative I can
essentially equate equal and opposite
parts of the left hand side so what this
means is that partial squared u partial
x squared equals this thing and this
thing equals minus partial u squared
partial Y squared okay
and so what that means is that I have
partial squared u partial x squared plus
partial squared u partial y squared
equals zero and this is just the
longhand form of Laplace's equation this
is just del squared u equals 0 so if the
coachee Ramond conditions hold meaning f
is analytic and I'm also I'm basically
assuming that if f is analytic then I
can take any higher derivative I want
and all partial derivatives that's fine
then I can essentially take partial
derivatives and through this mixed
partial term I can equate the partials
with respect to only X and the partials
with respect to only Y and I get this
nice cancellation so that they have to
equal zero you also can do the exact
same thing starting with the second hat
ideas you can also do the same thing
yeah you can just take the other partial
so you could take the partial of this
Koshi riemann one with respect to Y and
the cauchy-riemann partial with respect
to X and you can add up those terms and
you can get the other laplacian which is
partial squared v partial x squared plus
partial squared v partial y squared
equals 0 this also has to be true so
this is really special what this means
is that now we have a nice way of
finding solutions of Laplace's equation
okay so for every analytic function you
can name so for Z squared or sine of Z
or e to the Z all of these analytic
functions the real part in the imaginary
part both solve Laplace's equation and
Laplace's equation is really really
important for example Laplace's equation
would tell you what the infinite time
temperature distribution is on a surface
or what the gravitational potential is
in all of three space
or what the Coulomb potential field
looks like this is an extremely
important set of equations the Laplace
equation and now we're starting to
realize that the real and the imaginary
parts of analytic functions always solve
Laplace's equation very very interesting
and and they're related the real and the
imaginary parts are related via these
kosher iman conditions so these are so
special that they have a name so U and V
are called harmonic functions
and if you look in the course catalogue
at almost any major university in the
math department you'll find an entire
grad class on harmonic functions don't
recommend you taking it unless you
really really really really like complex
analysis but these are really important
functions they solve lots and lots of
PDS that we're going to look at in a
week or two okay okay are there any
questions about what we've been doing
with harmonic functions or how to
analyze these systems or what it means
to be harmonic because this would be the
time to take a step back and reflect on
things for a few minutes
so what are some examples of functions
that are not analytic what is it so what
it means to be analytic is that it's a
function is smooth you can take the
derivatives the derivative means what
you think it means so if I look at a
nice rolling Hill and I think of that
that nice rolling Hill is kind of like
an analytic function right the
derivative exists at every point and you
know I can take the second or the third
of the fourth derivative they're nice
and smooth it's like what we are used to
thinking about Z squared Z to the fourth
Z to the fourth minus Z squared sine of
Z all of these nice smooth well behaved
functions that are you can do calculus
on are analytic so what's an example is
something that's definitely not analytic
sorry
ok the mod function something that's
just continuous let's think of an
example it's easier to visualize 1 over
Z so 1 over Z is a good one we
essentially have I mean I can't really
draw this but in the complex plane we're
going to have something that looks like
a black hole right at Z equals 0 it goes
down to negative infinity right actually
probably not maybe it goes up to a
positive infinity too and maybe you
should flip my board but these things go
to positive and negative infinity
depending on what your real and
imaginary parts are so definitely
discontinuous the derivatives definitely
equal different things kind of epsilon
to the right or epsilon to the left or
Epsilon the plus or minus I directions 1
over Z is a nice example that's messed
up
I'm thinking more what I drew is log of
Z so log of Z looks more like a black
hole where you go down to negative
infinity at 0 so that's a good example
of a function that definitely is not
analytic at Z equals 0 1 over Z is not
analytic at Z equals 0 but it is
analytic away from there I think you
should be able to calculate the
derivative away from Z equals 0 what are
some other examples like what's the
basic
feature that we're starting to see here
singularities ok so division by zero
anytime I have a division by zero
I lose analyticity in some small
neighborhood around that point kind of
jumping the gun I'm telling you stuff
that is from next week but I want to do
this because I want you to be thinking
about examples of nice functions and
examples of tricky functions so you have
singularities which basically just means
you know divide by zero so something
that blows up to infinity in the complex
plane these are called poles don't ask
me why
examples are like 1 over Z or log of Z
or 1 over Z squared things like that and
these functions are not analytic what
are some other examples of things that
are not analytic that don't have
singularities step function so I was
thinking on the way over here of an
example and I'm thinking of like the
cliffs between Texas and New Mexico
right there are some steppe cliffs where
you have high plains this is like where
wily coyote lives I can't really draw
that well and so you could walk up here
on this part to the end of the cliff but
then you'd have to fall all the way down
to walk down here on the bottom ok so
this function is analytic here and
analytic here but it's not analytic on
the boundary of these two steps
there's no singularity but it's just
discontinuous the derivatives don't
exist at that point ok so what I'm
trying to do is essentially just build
your intuition for the fact that these
analytic functions are not anything
magical or mystical or crazy the Koshi
Riemann conditions are just nice ways of
testing that these things don't happen
but you don't have singularities that
you don't have steps in the cliff that
you can compute derivatives ok
and what we're going to find is that
there are some really important
functions that do have isolated
singularities all of these singularities
are for example isolated at the origin z
equals 0 if i wanted i could create
something with a singularity 1 over z
minus a and now i have a singularity at
a or I could have log of Z minus a now
my singularities at a that's fine and
we're going to figure out how to
integrate around functions that are
analytic that are nice and we're also
going to find out how to integrate in
contours around nasty non analytic
functions around singularities so that's
kind of what we're going to be doing in
the the next you know week and we're
going to start now any questions about
this what it means to be analytic you
have lots of time to think well I race
the board its analytic over the entire
domain is that the only case that there
are monic or if it's and like over most
of the domain is in harmonic over to
main that's a good question so
so those functions U of x and y will
satisfy Laplace's equation at any points
x and y where our original function was
analytic so if there's some domain of
analyticity then that would be the
domain under which those functions U and
V are in fact harmonic yeah so you can
have like restricted domains or their
harmonic that's actually a nice segue
into what we're going to be talking
about so let's say that I have a
function okay so say f is analytic on a
domain D okay now I'm going to use this
a lot this is kind of an abstraction and
I'll tell you what I mean in a little
bit but the basic idea is that I have
this nice blue area in the complex plane
where F is well behaved so this is my
complex plane this is the real part X
the imaginary part Y and this is the
complex plane this is my domain D in
blue and outside of this domain I might
have some really nasty stuff and I have
lots of polls and singularities these
might all be black holes okay but here
my function is nice and smooth and
analytic yeah
so for now I'm going to say that D is a
simply connected domain and what that
means is that it doesn't have any holes
in it okay this is a topological ah'd of
topology in advanced complex analysis
but the basic idea is that simply
connected is something where it's a blob
like it's one blob with no holes in it
and you could continuously deform it
away as opposed to something like a
doughnut
which is not one single blob it does
have a hole in it and any ways that you
try to continuously deform this this
doughnut you're still going to have a
hole in the center there's no way to get
rid of it okay so we don't want these
this is simply connected and you can
have really weird shapes that are simply
connected I can have something that
snakes around
that's simply connected this is
topologically the same as a circle not a
doughnut this doesn't have any holes in
it I could I could deform this in
play-doh and have one big spherical blob
as opposed to this where there's no way
to deform that without smashing the hole
away okay good question so this is a
simply connected domain okay and so
we're going to start thinking about how
to do contour integrals in the complex
plane how many of you have seen Laplace
transforms before okay
did you use Laplace transforms to solve
oh DS P DS okay so how many of you
remember how to compute the inverse
Laplace transform is it a lookup table
or is there a formula for it
sorry so most of us use tables but it
turns out that there is this integral in
the complex plane so you integrate over
this big contour see and there's
probably a bunch of nasty poles that
you're integrating around
weird singularities and stuff and so for
example we want to be able to integrate
functions in the complex plane because
it's going to allow us to compute
inverse Laplace transforms
that's if if it wasn't for Laplace
transforms I would not be telling you
about complex analysis period I thought
about it I thought how can I get away
with not teaching complex analysis but I
realized I really want you to understand
where Laplace transforms come from and
how they originate and how to compute
these integrals because they're so
important in partial differential
equations Fourier transforms - ok so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take a function f and we're going to
start integrating it over contours C and
so let me just draw this contour C so
first I'm going to draw a path from Z 1
to Z 2 and I'm going to call that
contour 1 ok so what we're going to do
is we're going to integrate over this
contour f of z DZ and integrating
contours in the complex plane is
actually not super complicated I just
take F and I write it as real plus
imaginary part I take DZ and I write it
as real plus imaginary part and I expand
them out and I get ya u plus IV times DX
plus i dy equals udx minus vdy
plus I times V D X plus u dy u dy plus V
DX this is all under the integral okay
this isn't too complicated at this point
I just took my function and my
differential DX and I multiplied them
out and isolated them into real and
imaginary parts there's basically two
tricks in all complex analysis you
either expand things in real and
imaginary or you write them in polar
coordinates as R and data those are the
two things that we always go to and you
just see which one gives you something
that looks nice okay so what I'm going
to tell you I'm going to say that it's a
theorem I don't think we're going to
prove it but it's important this is just
a fact when I say theorem this just
means that there's a fact that you can
use a usable fact is that if F is
analytic in D and D has those nice
properties that simply connected closed
region it doesn't have any holes in it
then the integral of f of zdz is
independent of path it's independent of
the path that I took to get from Z 1 to
Z 2 so for example I could have taken a
totally different path from Z 1 to Z 2 I
could have taken C 2 and as long as C 1
and C 2 both live inside of this nice
simply connected analytic domain D then
both of these integrals are equal to
each other I haven't told you why yet
I'm about to tell you why
so what we have is you know integral of
C 1 f of zdz equals integral of C 2 f of
Z DZ pretty interesting okay what are
some other systems we've looked at where
this type of thing is true where the
integral doesn't depend on the path
conservative vector fields right so if I
take a 50-pound mass and I climb it up a
hill my potential energy change doesn't
it's going to be the same no matter
which path I take up the hill as long as
I go from the same height zero to the
same height 1 ok that's an example of a
conservative vector field and the idea
is you can read about the details in my
notes but the basic idea is that both
both of these are what are called exact
differentials if my function satisfies
the Koshi remind condition so these are
called exact differentials how do we
think about this it basically means that
there is some function big f of x and y
plus big i of g of x and y where this is
the derivative with respect to x and the
derivative with respect to Y of F and
same thing with respect to G so like u
equals F sub X this sub X means partial
partial x v equals minus partial F
partial Y and we also have u equals
partial G partial Y and V equals partial
G partial X
now remember that U and V satisfy
Laplace's equation what other systems
that we look at last chord is it
satisfied Laplace's equation the
potential flow and potential functions
right the gravitational potential
function was an example of a real valued
F so that if I took partial f of X and
partial F of Y then I would get
functions that satisfy Laplace's
equation so you can think of this as a
complex potential okay and grad of F
gives me my vector field the view
component and the V components or grad
of G gives me my my vector field okay so
I'm going to go a little bit fast past
this there are things you can do to
convince yourself that this is true what
I want you to know is that this is a
very very very very important fact if I
have a function which is analytic in a
domain D and I'm going to take the
integral from some point Z 1 to some
point Z 2 it doesn't matter how I take
that integral what path I take at all
that's the fact that matters okay and so
there's a really important ramification
of this called the Koshi Gore saw
theorem I haven't checked and seen if
Gore saw is on the Eiffel Tower but it
probably is
so the Koshi Gore saw theorem
so are there any conclusions that you
can draw immediately from the fact that
the integral over c1 and the integral
over C 2 are equal to each other yeah
exactly if I start at z1 and I end it z1
then that integral should be 0
regardless of the closed contour that I
take okay
that's the coachee course off here so
it's all the same stuff if f is analytic
over D blah blah blah blah blah so if F
dot dot dot you know analytic over a
simple closed curve in a domain D then
the closed integral of f of Z DZ equals
0 and I'm just going to draw this
picture so that you have it you have
some curve starting at Z naught and
ending at Z naught and this entire curve
lives inside of a nice well-behaved
analytic domain D it's analytic
everywhere here then this closed contour
integral always equals 0 okay you can
prove this using greens theorem and I'll
get you started and then you can follow
the rest of it this is the kind of thing
that might be an exam problem so if you
wanted to prove this then you would say
ok I'm going to take this expression
here so I have integral over this
contour of udx minus vdy plus I times
the integral of u dy plus V DX and I can
use greens theorem to turn these contour
integrals into surface integrals on the
entire internal area of this red curve
all right this is some surface s and by
greens theorem by green this equals some
double integral over s of minus partial
V partial X minus partial u partial Y
with respect to DX dy and then there's
an equivalent imaginary part plus I
times the double surface integral of
partial u partial X minus partial V
partial Y over DX dy now what can I say
about these sets of partial derivatives
sorry why are they equal to zero
because those are the Co Shiromani you
put conditions those each of these
integrands has to equal 0 when F is
analytic which is why this is only true
if the entire curve lives inside of a
analytic domain D ok so we're starting
to get some really really interesting
results here ok if I do a closed contour
integral over any complex function in a
domain where it's analytic then that
closed contour integral equals 0 so in
the homework you're going to actually do
a MATLAB example where we're going to
code up like sine of Z and we're going
to do this closed contour integral of
sine of Z and we're going to show that
we get 0 ok
okay I'm going to show you one geometric
sketch before the end of class and then
I think what I'm going to do next
lecture so on Monday I'm actually going
to code up in MATLAB this contour
integral I'm going to show you examples
of where this equals zero and where it
doesn't equal zero and we're going to
start thinking about what happens what
if I dropped a couple of singularities
in the center of this contour integral
what if what if D wasn't simply
connected what if it was like a doughnut
and there were some weird singularities
in here how does this integral formula
change okay that's where we're going is
we want to be able to integrate systems
that are mostly analytic but they have a
few singularities in them but don't
worry we'll get there
in due time on Monday okay so the idea
in this picture that I want to draw is
that inside some analytic domain D so
we're analytic everywhere in this domain
D then if I have to contour integrals I
can essentially deform this contour into
any other closed contour integral I want
so c1 and c2 I mean of course these are
equivalent because they both integrate
to 0 okay but this is also true see if I
can draw this it's also true in an
analytic domain like this
okay so these integrals over c1 and c2
are obviously equal because they both
equal 0 right so integral of C 1 of F
equals integral of C 2 of F but of
course they equal 0 they both equal 0
right but in this case the same thing is
true C 1 C 2 C 1 so here the same thing
is true integral over this contour C 1
of F equals integral of contour of C 2
of F but here they do not equal 0
because I have some weird singularities
in here the course she Gore the co she
Gore saw theorem that we derived doesn't
hold here basically because greens
function is not satisfied inside of here
that those integrals don't equal 0
because I have weird stuff where Koshi
riemann is not true in the middle here
and so the picture that I like to draw
here is essentially that I can take
these two integrals and I can draw a new
one
bear with me this is not the best art
ever
okay where this outer one was c1 this
inner one is minus c2 and these are
infinitesimally close together these two
kind of straight lines these are epsilon
apart
okay now this red curve is everywhere
analytic and I can draw that simply
connected blue thing that I had before
here so D now is simply connected and
analytic everywhere here and the idea is
that this closed curve this closed red
curve does have zero integral this does
satisfy the Koshi course ah theorem
because my blue curve is simply
connected so I have this new integral of
C one plus integral of minus C 2 plus
integral of plus epsilon plus integral
of minus epsilon does equal 0 because
Koshi riemann is true in this whole blue
area and greens theorem applies and so
the koushaku or saw theorem holds now I
said that these two were infinitesimally
close to each other and so they exactly
cancel out and so I have that the
integral of C 1 equals minus the
integral of minus C 2 and if you
integrate something in the minus
direction that's just minus of the
integral in the positive direction so I
have integral of C 1 equals integral of
positive C 2 even though both of those
integrals are finite they're nonzero ok
so this is just an example of the kinds
of surgery you can do on the complex
plane
I call this surgery because we did a
exelon incision and we made our blue
region simply connected and then we were
able to do this coach igor saw theorem
these integrals are not equal to zero
but they're equal to each other so i can
deform c 1 into c 2 as long as both of
them live entirely in
analytic domain D I want you to think
about this this is not super simple it's
not obvious but it's really important so
think about this make sure that you
understand every step that we took to
get this expression okay I'll see you on
Monday
you